[MUSIC PLAYING]
KSENIIA SHUMELCHYK:
Hello, my name is Kseniia.
I am a bioengineer and Google
developer expert for Android.
I am from Ukraine.
Dnipro is my hometown where
I grew up and studied.
I have started learning
programming with my elder
brother 15 years ago.
Internet was not common,
so I took paper notes.
My career started with the
Google Summer of Code program,
where I have met
other participants
from Ukraine and local Google
developer group community.
In 2015, I was selected as
Google Anita Borg scholar.
And that was a
turning point for me.
Since this program, I met
a lot of outstanding women
who became friends, colleagues,
and role models for me.
Personal connections are
the greatest resources
you could have at I/O. And
together with open mind,
it can lead to new,
innovative ideas.
Me and my little Droids
will be glad to see you
at Google I/O 2018.
[MUSIC PLAYING]